[Musica]
io punto mi chiama nadia rucci e sono
ricercatrice professoresse ricercatrice
all'università dell'aquila in realtà
appunto come è stato già detto ho messo
questa bellissima foto che è un alba sul
bellissimo mare di vasto per
sottolineare il fatto che io pur non
essendo nata basso vi ho vissuto la mia
infanzia
e fino all'età di 20 anni qui quindi per
me veramente un piacere un onore e sono
più particolarmente emozionata di
ritrovarmi qui dopo tanti anni e sono
qui appunto questa sera con voi perché
ho avuto diciamo questa grandissima
occasione mi è stata appunto offerta
dall aic
ho avuto la fortuna e l'onore di essere
stata finanziata voi sapete che in
italia i finanziamenti per la ricerca
sono ridotti al lumicino quindi per noi
avere ricevere un finanziamento
di una portata piuttosto diciamo
consistente è una boccata di ossigeno
per fare ricerca devi fare affidamento
su queste
fondazioni parlo appunto dell'airc ma
pensiamo anche a telethon per quanto
riguarda le malattie genetiche e quindi
è stata che è stato veramente un onore e
una responsabilità per me avere questo
finanziamento
però questa sera vi parlerò un po sia
della ricerca in generale ma anche di
quello che faccio che faccio io nel mio
nel mio laboratorio
ovviamente se parliamo di di tumori di
arche di tumori l'argomento è dei più
felici però io qui questa sera voglio
darvi un po qualche diciamo barlume di
speranza ho preso un paio di diapositive
che dio non può lo stato dell'arte non
solo in italia ma anche in altri paesi
e che cosa ci dice questo grafico se ne
guardiamo diciamo la linea arancione
vediamo che c'è un aumento purtroppo dei
casi di di morti per tumore ma in realtà
questa non è diciamo la situazione reale
perché noi dobbiamo
normalizzare questo dato diciamo
rispetto alla popolazione totale quindi
se noi vediamo la striscia la linea blu
vediamo che in realtà c'è stato una c'è
stata una riduzione
della mortalità per cancro questa
diciamo seguire l'andamento della
mortalità quindi si parla di
tasso di mortalità per cui numero di
persone morte per cancro normalizzate
per la popolazione totale e questo è
importante perché perché nel corso degli
anni
ovviamente è aumentata l'aspettativa di
vita la
vita media si è allungata
ci sono più anziani e quindi ovviamente
è soprattutto nei soggetti anziani che
si manifestano questo tipo di patologie
quindi diciamo dobbiamo vedere quella
che è la linea la linea blu che è un
calo nel tempo c'è un'altra l'altro
grafico successivo non so se si vede
bene però di guida ero io in cui diciamo
la linea verde
indica la sopravvivenza nel 1971
paragonata al 2011 ovviamente dati non
sono aggiornatissimi marta nello stesso
e vediamo fondamentalmente che per
esempio per noi ci sono queste queste
frecce verdi il carcinoma della mammella
c'è stato un raddoppio della
sopravvivenza vedete la linea diciamo
l'istogramma rosa quindi la
sopravvivenza aveva doppiate addirittura
per quanto riguarda il prostata quindi
quello più in basso la sopravvivenza è
quadruplicato nel tempo quindi diciamo
questi sono sono messaggi di speranza
e questo diciamo rappresenta il primo
effetto domino cioè vediamo che nel
tempo
tante piccole ricerche tanti piccoli
pasti avanti negli anni hanno permesso
di
raggiungere questo risultato è di
continuare di cercare di migliorare
questo risultato quindi sicuramente c'è
un effetto domino nel tempo tante
piccole tesserine ricerca prevenzione
diagnosi che ci aiutano a migliorare
diciamo a combattere questa questo
questo mare è infatti quali sono le
strategie per diciamo per poter agire
contro i tumori contro il cancro sono
parole chiave sono sempre le stesse ma
sono essenzialmente tutte importanti
prevenzione prevenire la prevenzione è
fondamentale
più si conosce questa patologia e più si
può prevenire diagnosi precoce quindi
possibilità di identificare dei
marcatori che siano in grado di
evidenziare la patologia il prima
possibile e poi ovviamente terapia
terapia che deve essere qui ho messo
questa questa immagino terapia mirata
adesso che cosa si fa si cerca di fare
una terapia personalizzata perché
purtroppo c'è una notevole eterogeneità
nei tumori nelle diverse nei diversi
individui una terapia mirata soprattutto
alle cellule tumorali e cioè andare a
diciamo a distruggere la cellula
tumorale mantenere le cellule sane
quindi non
non andare a colpire le cellule sane
quindi selettività della terapia e poi
ovviamente la ricerca la ricerca che è
fondamentale e qui ho messo di nuovo il
logo airc perché ripeto ci dà una da una
grande mano hanno i ricercatori ecco
come si fa la ricerca fondamentalmente
si parte da una ipotesi ognuno di noi un
ricercatore studia studia vede quello
che c'è in letteratura e fa delle
ipotesi ovviamente queste ipotesi devono
essere diciamo
dimostrate a volte la nostra ipotesi è
giusta altre volte un po meno e quindi
noi possiamo immaginare diciamo il
nostro percorso un po come un labirinto
sappiamo che l'uscita cioè alla fine
dobbiamo cercare solo di individuarle
quindi dobbiamo fare diversi tentativi
prove alla fine riuscire a appunto a
trovare questa quest'uscita
e questa è una frase molto importante
che noi ricercatori utilizziamo che noi
dobbiamo che noi ricercatori dobbiamo
avere a mente è che un po e quello è
l'effetto domino che ci dà alla fine
fronte banks to the bad side cioè dal
bancone quindi dal laboratorio dal
balcone di ricerca attraverso una serie
di step che sono appunto esperimenti in
vitro il vivo e trials clinici noi
arriviamo alla terapia cioè bad side che
sarebbe il diciamo e letto del paziente
quindi noi pur facendo come si dice nel
gergo ricerca di base cioè utilizzando
modelli in vitro e quant'altro dobbiamo
sempre avere come obiettivo il paziente
cioè deve essere chiarendone l'empatia
cioè capire che al di là di questo
bancone
il nostro obiettivo finale è quello di
rendere di rendere la vita di un
paziente
migliore di migliorare appunto la sua
aspettativa di vita ed eventualmente di
curarlo quindi è una cosa molto
importante questa noi spesso diciamo
divaghiamo pensiamo i nostri esperimenti
e perdiamo di vista quello che è
l'obiettivo finale
e quindi questo è sicuramente un un
effetto domino partire dall'ipotesi
arrivare alla alla terapia andando
diciamo a studiare il mio mio intervento
ho pensato poi al fatto che esiste un
altro effetto domino è un effetto domino
di tipo diciamo il precedente era un
effetto domino temporale nel tempo noi
abbiamo tutte queste tappe raggiungiamo
la terapia ma c'è anche un effetto
domino
spaziale potremmo dire il fatto cioè che
tutti i laboratori del mondo
sono in grado di interagire fra di loro
c'è una forte interconnessione tra noi
cioè io in tempo reale dell'università
dell'aquila università che non è diciamo
che è un umile università possa sapere
quello che fanno i ricercatori alla
columbia di new york cioè tra noi
ricercatori c'è una forte solidarietà
cioè la capacità di fare data sharing
cioè di far conoscere agli altri dati e
quindi questa interconnessione è
fondamentale ed è proprio questa
interconnessione che ci permette di
avere un effetto domino
importante per la ricerca quindi
contrariamente a quello che sta
succedendo nel mondo dove si vedono
diciamo purtroppo cose spiacevoli la
ricerca invece accomuna molto ci
accomuna dal punto di vista proprio di
diverse di capacità di interagire fra di
noi e quindi di parlare anche con i
ricercatori che sono all'altro capo del
mondo e mettere a disposizione le nostre
conoscenze
andiamo quindi alla mia ricerca che cosa
sto facendo io io mi occupo in realtà di
una situazione un po più complicata
rispetto ai tumori io mi occupo di
metastasi ossee e qui bisogna aprire una
parentesi perché purtroppo fin quando si
parla di tumore di un tumore i tumori
attualmente si può diciamo per la
maggior parte di essi si può dire che
sono curabili
c'è una persona malata di un tumore può
guarire
il problema vero e quando insorge la
metastasi cioè quando le cellule
tumorali lasciano il tumore primario e
vanno a metastatizzare in siti distanti
e questo diciamo una fase che purtroppo
la metastasi viene considerata ancora
come una malattia incurabile è però una
malattia trattabile ovviamente il nostro
obiettivo è quello di rendere curabile
anche la metastasi le metastasi però nel
frattempo quello che possiamo fare sono
due cose intanto migliorare
l'aspettativa di vita aumentare
l'aspettativa di vita del paziente cioè
tutti i pazienti hanno diritto ad una
speranza anche se sono metastatici e
quindi noi dobbiamo cercare di aumentare
l'aspettativa di vita ma non è solo
questo il problema il problema è anche
quello di migliorare la qualità della
vita è molto importante
e appunto
garantire una qualità della vita
dignitosa e e quindi diciamo
studiare le metastasi è molto importante
questo è il mio laboratorio
io sono ovviamente tutti mascherati
nel laboratorio diciamo ci sono ragazzi
di tutte le età potete vedere e sono
ragazzi di tutte le età grandi piccoli
tutti con una grande passione e con la
voglia di fare qui c'è un ragazzo
marco che tra l'altro è stato finanziato
con una borsa di studio da airc e cioè
like oltre a dare i soldi a me per fare
gli esperimenti finanzia anche lo
stipendio dei giovani ricercatori e
questo è fondamentale anche questo
importantissimo e che cosa facciamo nel
nostro laboratorio ok questo diciamo noi
ci occupiamo di metastasi ossee in
particolar modo di metastasi ossee da
carcinoma della mammella
quindi andiamo a studiare perché una
cellula dal suo sito primario va in
qualche modo a raggiungere l'osso la
cosa importante
da dire è questa il processo metastatico
non è un processo casuale cioè lasciarla
tumorale non va in maniera del tutto
casuale a colonizzare un organo
piuttosto che un altro lasciare una
tumorale una volta arrivata in circolo
sceglie a un sito preferenziale di
metastasi quindi se noi conosciamo
questa cellula e sappiamo
che andrà per esempio all'osso e non al
fegato possiamo in questo modo
prevedere diciamo la metastasi e quindi
per esempio fare un trattamento che
prevenga lo sviluppo delle metastasi e
questo è quello che noi stiamo cercando
di studiare andiamo alla parte finale
che è il mio incontro con like io in
realtà sono
stata finanziata nel 2011 dall l'lhc è
stato il mio primo finanziamento e
allora io ero una cosiddetta precaria
cioè
lavoravo con contratti annuali rinnovati
ogni anno quindi per me avere questo
finanziamento è stata una doppia una
doppia vittoria da una parte mi sono
sentita gratificata perché evidentemente
avevano diciamo creduto nel mio progetto
e poi perché avere un finanziamento ti
permette di fare ricerca di pubblicare e
di avere un curriculum e quindi poi di
applicare per posizioni stabili quindi
per me è stata una vera e propria
boccata di ossigeno
in realtà poi
nel 2020 quindi due anni fa o
riapplicato di nuovo e diciamo avuto di
nuovo la fortuna di avere quest altro
finanziamento
ricevere una lettera del genere è una
gioia indescrivibile quando ti arriva
una lettera che non si vede bene gentile
professoressa lucia insomma ti ti ti
senti tremare la terra sotto i piedi è
una sensazione diciamo veramente di
appagamento
cosa studiamo noi studiamo queste eccole
qui le vescicole extracellulari cosa
sono sono delle particelle di dimensioni
piccolissime sono dimensioni nanometri
che vengono rilasciate come vedete qui
dalle cellule sane e sono dei veicoli
contengono una serie di materiali nel
loro interno sono dei veicoli che le
cellule sane mandano in circolo vengono
anche rilasciate da altri studi core
pori per andare a diciamo
per andare a regolare organi a distanza
purtroppo anche dai cellule tumorali
fanno questo queste cellule tumorali
producono vescicole che potremmo
chiamare vescicole cattive perchè le
molecole che loro contengono sicuramente
diciamo non hanno effetti benefici
quindi vanno a distanza e per esempio
promuovono la metastatizzazione e
importante quindi conoscere la
differenza fra vescicole sane e
vescicole extracellulari di cellule
tumorali perché questo ci permette di
capire di avere una chiave di lettura e
di capire quali sono le molecole
sbagliate che si possono inibire
per cui che cosa faremo noi o anzi
quello che stiamo già facendo per
esempio andiamo praticamente a
vedere come queste pesci col
extracellulari sono in grado di andare a
diciamo creare la cosiddetta nicchia pre
metastatica cioè che significa una
cellula tumorale attraverso queste le
scivole manda questo messaggio a
distanza nell'osso e prepara l'osso a
ricevere la cellula tumorale come se
queste vescicole fossero dei
fertilizzanti per cui quando poi
lasciarla tumorale aviv riesce a
sopravvivere e ad attecchire se quindi
noi blocchiamo questo passaggio
possiamo bloccare la metastatizzazione
il secondo il secondo obiettivo è quello
di utilizzare queste pellicole
extracellulari come biopsie liquide cioè
isoliamo vescicole extracellulari
derivanti dal tumore e in questo modo
possiamo fare diagnosi possiamo fare un
follow up della terapia cioè seguire nel
tempo come va la terapia se efficace e
soprattutto prevedere il rischio di
metastasi e in ultima analisi l'ultima
diapositive questa utilizzare sempre
queste pellicole per caricarle con dei
farmaci chemioterapici le ingegneri
siamo facciamo in modo che queste
pellicole vadano soltanto alle cellule
tumorali e rilasciano questo questi
chemioterapici soltanto alle cellule
tumorali lasciando quindi le cellule
sane non toccando le cellule sane
io ho qua ho concluso vorrei diciamo
lasciarvi con questa frase che a me ha
molto colpito e che credo vada piuttosto
bene per quanto riguarda quell'effetto
domino di cui parlavamo prima mi piace
diciamo sottolineare questo che noi
appunto siamo come nani sulle spalle di
giganti
così che possiamo vedere più cose di
loro è più lontane non certo per l'acume
della vista all altezza del nostro corpo
ma perché siamo sollevati e portati in
alto dalla statura dei giganti e questa
è una frase di un filosofo del
1.159 quindi molto antica
l'ultima diapositiva sono soltanto
ringraziamenti grazie a basso questa è
un'altra bella immagine grazie ad a e
studia mente dietro light ci siete voi
voi che donate quindi noi io vi
ringrazio personalmente per questo e
dulcis in fondo la mia famiglia i miei
figli è una foto di circa undici anni fa
non ha niente a che vedere con i figli
adesso che sono una tornata ieri da
firenze rocks quindi non è lei
per le mamme i figli rimangono sempre
piccoli spero di non aver tolto a loro
un qualche cosa per lavorare troppo una
cosa positiva l'ho fatta sicuramente ho
scelto un padre c'è un paso eccellente
nonché mio compagno quindi da quel punto
di vista non mi possono dire niente
grazie a scritti
grazie